the jurgen experience was that something
that it always called to you
being an actor no not really um i was
gonna go into
be a doctor or something like that you
know i was always really good in school
and
uh but uh my father was a bus driver
in the bronx and this and and uh he
started doing community theater when i
when i was
in high school like he was like 40. just
almost
one day starts acting in plays which
looking back
knowing what it takes it's very
courageous you know somebody to do that
and uh so i always saw cool movies and
even saw some theater in new york
because my parents took me
but then in my last year of high school
i was like well what the hell what do
you really want to do
i mean if you can do anything i really
literally asked myself that question if
you could do anything
what would it be and i was like i got
you know i really didn't want to stay in
school for
10 years either like studying i was kind
of sick of that and then come out in
debt
come out in debt and that's the big one
that's a big one
it flavors the way they live their life
yeah they live their life
starting out of the gate in their career
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt
yeah and not just doctors right yeah
even even people who don't even go to
grad school sure
go through yeah that's really rough so
you asked yourself that question and how
did you come up with acting
yeah i started i had some good teachers
in high school who like brought us to
theater and and
and i was reading a lot of plays in high
school in the library in my school
and and just got into it more and more
my last
year or two of high school i wasn't
acting i didn't do any acting then
and then after high school i went to uh
an acting school in new york
and took a couple of classes there and
then stayed for
for a long time actually with the couple
with a teacher
and met a lot of people that i still
work with today back then you know
who were a couple who were on the
sopranos actually is live performance
is that your love like theater um
you know it is i mean i love all of it i
mean it
it's always about the specific project
and the material and the people you're
with but
doing it live is really special because
a you're doing the whole
story every night from beginning to end
right and you have
you're on stage for whatever two hours
it's that concentration and that
commitment you know movies and
television as you know is broken up into
little bits
throughout the day and and um it's a
different kind of
concentration but there is something
special about
being in front of an audience it's
different every night the reactions are
different every night and there's a
interplay that's very exciting
so do you still do it now do you go back
and forth
i mean theater i mean i did um i hope to
start doing it again soon
you know um at one point my wife and i
built a theater and we were we were
producing new plays where'd you build
them west 29th street manhattan
around i think we opened in 2003. so
when you say built the theater like what
was there before
i was just like a raw space i think it
was a it was a
club at one point and then literally my
wife and my father-in-law built it like
and it looked like a theater from from
like 100 years ago it was beautiful how
did you get the craftsmanship to
like where did you get the people to do
that kind of work um
my wife and my father-in-law they did it
all themselves they did a lot i mean
there were a couple of people that they
contract certain things out for but a
lot he was he passed away but he was a
master
carpenter he was just brilliant and my
wife's really good how many seats was it
75 seats it was very intimate
and we did only new plays that had never
been done and uh
and we also had classes there acting
what year was this
between 2003 and like
2010. so this is a real labor of love
yeah it's not like you can make a lot of
money off of 70 no we didn't make
money no it cost it actually wound up
costing that's why we went out of
business but after the economy collapsed
we lost a lot of our funding you know we
lost all the corporate funding pretty
much
we had a few private you know donors who
really loved what we were doing and i
mean i
built the theater basically i did a a
movie
kind of a so good movie for uh harvey
weinstein actually
oh wow and that money went and built the
theater wow
that had to be a really interesting
thing
like the moment you're on stage that on
this theater that you built
yeah and you're you're performing these
plays i mean that that had to be a dream
realized that'd be a pretty special
moment
yeah i didn't act that much there i did
more directing
i mean we produced all the plays i did i
directed a bunch of them
i think i i only acted in one of them
but um but it was kind of
the inmates running the asylum really
because it was it wasn't really a
company but it was accompanied by
default because there were a lot of
people that
go-to people that i you know worked with
but it was
yeah it was really uh rewarding my wife
built all the sets for all the shows as
well as built the place itself
so intimate 75 cents really intimate
yeah
really intimate that's a wild decision
to make
to build your own theater it was her
idea i i wouldn't have done it
probably because as i had done i had
worked in theater i started producing
theater in my early 20s you know with a
company and
and um i knew what it you know it's hard
it's
it's not a good business model right um
but if you have the kind of passion and
we just found a way to do it she's like
no we'll build
i was like um but it was really fun
while it lasted
hmm
[Applause]